who started the top number one the 1248
your being up to simplified now hi a bit
the word supersize a little bit
ambiguous sometimes it means one thing
and sometimes need another but this at
this point you can see everything is
underneath the square root and we're
trying to see if we can take anything
out from underneath the square root so
this I can see is pretty outdated
heuristic Oh terrific
that's what all good where day yes it is
full so have a look at how he's done it
maybe you just keep on a pool of these
lights and you still the right at the
right hand side that's not necessarily a
bad thing but I really liked it all the
lines are their first line he looked at
48 and he just broken it up his
saturated
he chose 16 and 3 it's not the only way
you could do it you could do to a 24 or
4 and 12 or 6 and 8 or 9 I guess most of
us okay I'll put it straight in 1603
- good choice why why 16 you are 16 is a
square number and not only the square
it's the biggest we can be in there for
is square as well but once you take four
hours where you can still take more
stuff so you've taken up 16 good choice
he's then separated one square root
Institute do you remember this the last
sort of under more legal dad yesterday
it's brick into the pie and then it I
don't really finish and that good job
your forestry and now look here you can
see some of its in skip over our because
we've got straightened church worries
but it's not looking okay do you agree
the 16 times 20 is good yes okay it's
okay if the first square you think of
isn't the biggest one because you can
see the next line who resident wants to
okay Arriva seen always but I can I can
bring up 20 but that's cool you just
keep on working at this becomes for
these broken isms to that becomes to
every five looks perfect
yes so not so okay if you're getting the
hang of it let's start to go to Aziz or
more quickly to the square root of 200
you can actually just see a hundred
quite quickly and take that out the
square root of hundred and ten then what
happen to you
what if enough want to take your place
ten on the numerator and 5 on the
denominator there's common factor there
so that's what's been carefully nearest
to R is 2 okay and then we have some
squaring to do i if you have a look at
this lines here and this may give either
the important one okay these odds where
I can keep lines working and that you
know what's happening with your square
and the whole thing
four and five is a square of this web
nine and seven is this being and this is
being square right that all checks out
good job
so if you've got all those
congratulations and then all that off
let me use type like negative of a
square
ah okay so great to mention that if what
you did was type into your calculator
just as an example this this gadget that
probably worked out with the our mr.
world you know that
remember those typing a next numeral
like this do you remember our type this
into my calculator if I type it the
wrong way it would think what I meant
was one times four over five do you
remember that if I touched the numbers
expresses okay now something almost
identical is happening here if you meant
to do negative 5 times negative 5 then
which one type is this okay when you do
this it is all order operation that's -
by sometimes yeah so that's why I had
you by next month just be careful when
you're squaring got negative recruiting
particular if you have already ruled off
the heading I'd like you make use adding
and subtracting
okay so before we get adding is
detecting service I will get adding and
subtracting another kind of trouble if I
succeed I'll just make it more
interesting
okay one if I said to you can we
calculate 1/2 minus 3/7 as the moment in
this current form
without a calculator I can't do this
right I actually have to spill with
these numbers a little bit I've changed
what they look like okay can you tell me
how I should change them
alright can come here yes okay so we'll
change the delay to result yeah you'll
hit a block how should I change the
delivers yeah so if I make new 714 I'm
pretty sure is 714 great what I did was
to get the denominator 14 I've got a
double it which means I should put the
double numerator so it sticks happy okay
and now of course I can actually
calculate okay okay
now the reason why we had to do that
first line get the comments nominated is
because these guys don't like to play
with each other right those different
denominators it is certain X so no
problem you can bet on and then off you
go thank you
however when it comes to serve what if
instead I gave you say root 2 minus root
7 okay how do we simplify this and the
answer is well you can't I fashioned in
size I'd like to play with each other
that's okay we can rewrite them in na
will but third the most antisocial
numbers that are out there root 2 root 7
there is nothing you can do to make them
play inside that is as simple as it gets
this is fully simplified
okay so if you've got servers and the
number underneath the square root sent
my way I wait I'm still down to show you
what that website actually called it's
called radical science I'm not even
making that up
it's called radical okay if the number
underneath the radical signs are
different and you can't change them so
they're the same then that's it that's
as simplified as gets root 2 plus root 3
that's it you can't add them together
anyway how whatever we can sometimes the
just be so that you can so underneath it
different circle EEG when you just need
one
okay so have a look at this one for our
second review now it looks kind of like
the one I just showed you right in that
the number underneath the radical
underneath the square root sign they're
different
okay ah but we did this that first one
in the ravine pressure I can look at
that we can use how can i rewrite the
square root of 200 small job into yet
large okay so not a hundred times to
figure that plus three root roots and
you become a little more comfortable
with me I think I'd be okay with you if
you can do it reliably and accurately I
mean you can't go straight to camera two
you see where I got the ten from yeah
that's a square closest yeah so that's
10 root 2 plus 3 root 2 okay so even
though they start with the same number
now they are and this is actually a lot
like algebra remembering your 7 we first
encountered algebra you'll learn about
collecting like terms that ring a bell
like the lectern so we're like oh if you
have to write those definite up that's
all good right well these guys are kind
of like X's 4 root 2 and so I can
collect them can hear three there gives
you 13 root 2 okay so just like you 5x
plus 3x is an 8 is 8 F this is Henry -
we were two together is 13 of them if I
had some other guys hanging on like a
root 3 on the end is there any way you
can twist and turn root 3 so it can be
shared with you know you're kind of
stuck so therefore it says you have to
look carefully at these numbers to see
what can I kind of work with these may
give you a more example and then ways to
know I'm actually stopped
so this is the last one we'll have a go
out then you can know after the lip
none of these thirds of the moment none
of these sentiments have the same number
underneath okay so I'll cut you a tune
with them at the moment however if I try
and move them twist similarly just like
the query 200 maybe some of them end up
as the same kind of stone I think for
lesson alright square root of 98 can you
think of a nice big square number that
divides into 98 49 very good so this is
actually the Twitter 49 times 2 okay
I'll put that to one side I'll
simplified in it what about the square
root of 18 can you do something with
that that's 9 times 2 isn't it ok block
1 that's the biggest square number you
can fit in verses 16 so it's 16 times 2
yeah okay let's simplify ah this is
seven Richard this is bravery and this
is yeah
I'll cook if you see them all combining
together then that's great if I had just
you know something like just hanging up
on the end square root 7 or 7 plus the
square root of 7 but the gross 7 there's
no way that nothing you can take out of
the 7 to change into a different number
that will make these kinds of things so
you just leave it there
and that's their take it's believed in
the flesh all right